[Music]
[Applause]
oh look there's some of the styrofoam
ending up over there grab all the start
from bring it over here let's clean up
all the trash well it's been about two
weeks since we built the Lego house and
we've had some rain storms and some
flooding and some some high winds and it
looks like the roof came down I think
somebody was here and mess with it a
little bit because that looks like
that's been neatly stacked there we
might have just fallen that way who
knows but but but it looks like it's
other than the roof it's held up pretty
well
yeah our house looks good our job today
is to take the Lego house down get the
bricks back to the house and then I got
to clean them up I mean there's a lot of
dirt on them pretty dirty yeah I love
this little camp stove I'm definitely
gonna be using that for ninety bucks is
the great camp stoves I'm gonna be using
this again in the future look at that
look look how it melted that is that
looks pretty cool inside if you ever
want to catch lots of earthworms just
lay down wet cardboard in the woods
you will get so many earthworms look
good right there there's an earthworm Oh
big one just went down there and there
look at all these earthworms oh there's
a healthy boy
[Applause]
[Music]
well it took three days to put it up in
one hour to take it down the boats
getting pretty full but I am determined
to make one trip I don't want to make
two trips one trip looks a little full
but looks are deceiving we still have
room for two cardboard boxes and
eight-foot piece of styrofoam two
children and myself just you watch
[Music]
all right guys be safe well we got the
boat loaded up but I didn't exactly feel
good about putting the children on top
of that pile so I'm just having them
walk home over land and not too many
bears they should be fine
[Music]
this needs more than a little push all
right we're off
[Music]
if I keep hitting that alarm it's gonna
be a long day just to do till about my
pontoon boat nothing to see here
some nice little football you got there
that's uh that's a nice bass there it
was not easy but we did and let's see if
we get this thing home with that leggo
sprinkled across the across the road all
right
back at the house hey I got a bunch of
scrap wood I need to burn up and it's
just a nice fun Saturday so we're
building a fire gonna roast some
marshmallows
what a lovely day hey guys
yay me recognize my bamboo poles from
some my fishing videos but need to get
rid of them so it's kind of a yard
cleaning project today is kind of a lazy
day just got a bunch of new items I want
to put the forge away for the summer and
want to get my boat ready to go
I put the forge away for the summer time
because it's so it's so hot I mean when
it's nice and cold outside forgings a
great activity but when it's 90 degrees
at night it's miserable so I don't do
any forging in the summertime
[Music]
this summer I'm gonna try something a
little different I've got a lot of
videos that I've been holding on to that
for a variety of reasons I just didn't
upload on a Saturday morning so kind of
on and off this summer I'm gonna try to
upload twice a week and see how you guys
like it and of course follow us on
Facebook and Instagram so you can leave
comments because YouTube has still
disabled comments on the outdoor boy's
channel so you know just kind of living
with that but that's gonna be a good
summer we got some great videos coming
up once again here I am cleaning my
garage is a constant battle you know you
guys have no idea how much time it takes
to do all these videos and I literally
sprint from work to fishing from fishing
to putting the kids to bed
you know sprint to work thanks
more--it's and most the time when I get
done with fishing trips I just chuck
everything in the garage and then run to
the next thing I'm doing I just don't
have time to put everything away it just
gets crazy very quickly well this week I
suffered a devastating loss last week we
were in Outer Banks and we were there
for a week and I did a lot of filming it
and when we came back or was editing the
video and my laptop crashed and I lost a
lot of footage I was able to salvage
some of it but the end result was I lost
an entire Captain Cook video I had how
to catch clean and cook the puffer fish
video we're with fishing for bloat ODEs
and it is all gone I was a great video
too I've got so much random stuff in my
garage
the life of a youtuber right there well
put them over here with my collection of
ps3 and xbox 360s right next to the
Viking head I had a quarter of a cowhide
[Music]
so take my boat to the lake really quick
just to make sure the engine turns on
everything's working okay cuz I'm
thinking about taking my kids to the
Great Dismal Swamp on Monday and I'd
have to leave really early so I want to
make sure everything is working with the
boat before I go because you don't want
to get stranded in the Great Dismal
Swamp also I've got some fishing gear in
the back and I am 3/4 of the way through
a carp fishing video and I just need to
catch kind of one more fish and then
that should top off the video so I'm
gonna check the boat do some carp
fishing and hopefully that'll be it very
productive day
plenty of water pressure but there's a
little bit of blue smoke which usually
means you're burning oil or something I
think I figured it out I left the choke
open once it gets going you're supposed
to shut the toe
no it's purred like a kid alright it's
about 8:00 p.m. and I'm just trying to
get a little bit of fishing in got about
45 minutes I I can dedicate to this
hopefully I'll pull carp out but if not
we'll just have to try again later this
week I'm seeing white millet all over
the the boat ramp here and I think it's
from a mouse storing my carp bait inside
my trailer and when I launch the boat it
just dumped out all this millet check it
out tons of it all over the place I
caught one fish about 30 minutes in now
it's getting time to head home so I'm
doing the slow pack up I pull out one
more fish good vibe you know I mentioned
my garage always gets dirty because they
don't have any time this is a classic
example it's not a clock it's an hour
pass the boys bedtime if I hurry I get
to put my own children to bed and then
I'm going to work on video editing until
about midnight and not get done with
everything I need to do tonight and so
I'm gonna just take all the gear leave
it in the back of my car I'm just gonna
put the bait away so it doesn't rot my
car I'm just gonna push the boat in I'm
gonna shut the door and I'm not gonna
put away any of my gear because I'd
rather put my kids to bed if you liked
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching